fried fish eggplant and potato patties
in the old town of Rabat visitors are
tempted by a wide variety of Moroccan
delicacies fine food plays an important
role in the North African country and
much of it is homemade the fish is
freshly caught from the ocean the silver
fish factory near Casablanca is one of
the country's largest it employs around
1,000 people who process sardines about
60% of it is exported the products are
sold under various brand names the Nixa
brand name is made for the German market
and is certified this certification
allows us to sell our products in the
European and international markets we're
certified eco-friendly products are
worth more but the certification has no
influence on prices here in Morocco the
domestic market is also important
Moroccans call sardines the poor man's
fish one kilo goes for less than 2 euros
some 40% of Moroccans work in
agriculture or the fishing industry but
experts warn of overfishing fish
production plays a key role in the
national economy and it has a future but
we can't allow ourselves to concentrate
solely on fishing because resources are
limited at some point these natural
resources will be depleted
fish production is an important sector
for Morocco annual sales total some 1
billion euros and that's set to triple
by 2020 so an appearance at Berlin's
green week comes just at the right
moment